-Enjoy yourself.
Thank you.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you
for watching at home, too.
Guys, I want to say congrats
to the Kansas City Chiefs
on winning the Super Bowl.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Discordant celebration music
plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Sorry.
Sorry -- sorry, Roots.
-[ Groans ]
-Tariq is really
laughing it up tonight.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
The final score
was Chiefs, 38, Eagles, 35.
People who called out sick
to work, 19 million.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
That's right.
Today, a record 19 million
Americans were expected
to miss work.
Yep. We all woke up this morning
and chugged Gatorade
as if we actually played
in the game.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Patrick Mahomes won
the Super Bowl
on an injured ankle,
but fans can't show up to work
because they drank
too much White Claw.
[ Laughter ]
19 -- 19 million
people missed work.
Apparently, some of them used
a special excuse generator.
Have you heard about it?
I'll show you how it works.
For example,
when your boss asks,
"Why didn't you come in today?",
it tells you to say...
[ Beeping ]
"I tried, but on my way in,
my Tesla exploded."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's -- It's any excuse.
-Yeah.
-It helps you.
Next up, when your boss asks,
"Well, then, why aren't you
working remotely?", just say...
[ Beeping ]
"My Internet is being blocked by
a Chinese spy balloon."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-This is work.
-Yeah.
-And, finally,
when your kids ask,
"Why do we have to go to school
if you don't have to go
to work?", you just say...
[ Beeping ]
"You need good grades
to get a scholarship
because I lost your college fund
on DraftKings."
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Very helpful machine.
-Yeah, very helpful.
-Did you guys see this?
Before the game,
Chris Stapleton, amazing,
sang the national anthem.
And during his performance,
Eagles coach Nick Sirianni
got a little emotional.
Take a look at this.
♪ The bombs bursting in air ♪
♪ Gave proof ♪
[ Laughter ]
-God only knows what he looked
like after they lost.
[ Laughter ]
Must've been a puddle
with a headset.
Meanwhile, everyone
was talking about this.
The NFL used a new type of grass
that took two years to prepare,
and it was so slippery that
the players were falling down
on it the entire game.
Yeah, always smart to try
something new on the biggest
game of the year, I think.
[ Laughter ]
But the NFL actually released
a statement defending the grass.
They said,
"This is way funnier."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Funnier if they fall around.
"Whoa!"
"That's a good one."
One of the biggest moments
of the night, of course,
was Rihanna's amazing halftime
show that she did solo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That she did solo.
Yeah, well, it turns out
she did actually have a guest,
because during her performance,
Rihanna revealed
that she's pregnant.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
Rihanna did a Super Bowl
halftime show while pregnant.
Meanwhile, everyone at home
on their 30th chicken wing
was like, "I also felt a kick."
[ Laughter ]
Imagine it's the first day
of kindergarten
and your fun fact is that
you've done the Super Bowl
halftime show.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is big.
Today, Rihanna announced
that the gender reveal
will be at the Olympics.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-I read that, last night,
a 30-second commercial spot
cost more than $7 million.
Wow.
You plan it for months,
pay a ton of money, then the big
moment's over in 30 seconds.
It's basically Valentine's Day.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-That's right.
Tomorrow is Valentine's Day,
which means a lot of people
are exchanging cards,
including famous people.
And I don't know how this
happened, but we actually
got ahold of
some of these famous --
-Really?
-Yes. Yeah, I don't kno--
-That's insane.
-Well, we get them --
We have a lot of people --
-How did you do it?
How did you get them?
-We have a lot of fans of
"The Tonight Show,"
people working for us...
-Right.
-...finding these cards and...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...getting it to us before
the famous couple exchanges it.
-That's so great.
And you're gonna share them
with the audience?
-I'd love to, if you don't mind.
-I'd love -- [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is that okay?
Why not?
That's what I do.
That's why I'm here.
First, here's one that
Mike Pence sent to his wife.
It says that, "You're the
only woman that's ever..."
you open it up, it says,
"...seen me in my
full-body underwear."
-Aww.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Romantic.
Here's one
that Jay-Z sent to Beyoncé.
It says, "I would do anything
for...", you open it up,
it says. "...tickets
to your upcoming tour."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's very hard to get.
Here's one that Zach,
the Bachelor,
sent to one of the contestants.
It says,
"Katie, there's no one else
like you...", you open it up,
it says, "...aside from
the three other Katies
I'm also dating."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Besides that,
you're the only one.
Here's -- I thought this one
was really nice.
-Really?
-Here's one that Chiefs coach
Andy Reid sent to his wife.
It says, "Today, I gift you...",
you open it up, it says,
"...half a box of chocolates."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Isn't that nice?
[ Laughs ]
And finally,
here's one that Patrick Mahomes
sent to his wife.
It says,
"I think about you all the time.
You're my inspiration...",
you open it up, it says,
"Please deliver this card
to Tom Brady."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Roman-- It's romantic.
See? Happy Valentine's Day,
everybody.
Well, switching gears,
some political news.
I heard that
the Biden administration
is likely going to block the
JetBlue-Spirit airlines merger.
-Ooh.
-Yep, now all of JetBlue's
friends can be like, "Honestly,
we all hated Spirit."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, you guys
are going back out?"
"Oh, we love Spirit.
Seriously."
That's right,
Biden's gonna stop the merger,
or as they call it
in the airline world,
"a cockpit block."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-People --
People are talking about this.
I saw that an Italian restaurant
in New Jersey
is banning kids
under 10 years old.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
What?
It's New Jersey, so already,
9 year olds
are sliding the hostess a $20
like, "See what you can do.
All right?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is going viral.
A user on TikTok shared a story
about how her boyfriend
found a rubber glove
in his food at
The Cheesecake Factory.
[ Audience groans ]
Listen, if you're gonna find
something in your meal
that's rubber,
just be thankful it's a glove.
[ Laughter ]
In a related story, plenty of
Valentine's Day reservations
just opened up at
Cheesecake Factory,
so there you go.
You can get in.
[ Cheers and applause ]